foreign
[Music]
we are back at the Keswick theater
start talk live
and now we're gonna talk about black
holes for the next hour and a half
you got it
black holes and I I have some expertise
but not enough to fill the length of
this show okay so we combed the
landscape for my colleagues who spend
their lives thinking about black holes
yeah we found one of them at Princeton
University not even that far up the
street as far as distances go welcome to
the stage Jenny green professor of
astrophysics Jenny There She Goes
she's always known as the black hole
Hunter so you study supermassive black
holes and how to find them and where
they're located in the universe so
you're a black hole Hunter and you also
she is faculty director
of the prison teaching initiative at
Princeton
this is Princeton has a program
where
The Faculty go to the prison and teach
you teach algebra is that correct
correct so that the prisoners can come
out with some kind of a degree and
reduce the recidivism Yes We Salute You
next another black hole expert
one of our favorites she's a regular on
Star talk really and she is Professor of
physics and astronomy at Barnard and
Columbia University Jan 11. Jenna come
on out
so just so we understand the context
here
we have Jan 11 who approaches this
problem of black holes as a physicist
and she's interested in cosmology
space-time Continuum and the like
whereas we otherwise are searching for
actual black holes in the actual
universe and so these are two sides of
the same coin that we're going to
explore this evening nice so let's do
this all right
so
Janet hey hey hey how you doing all
right uh there was news yesterday
that there was a report that people
colleagues of ours have images
of where Jets these plumes of gas
viewing out from the centers of galaxies
that we have images of where that
connects down to a black hole at the
center could you please comment on that
yeah so the irony is that black holes
which are by definition the darkest
phenomenon conceivable in the universe
are the brightest beacons as well
because they figure out a way how to
access all the energy and Light and
Power around them so they power these
Jets we can see the Jets at Great
distances sometimes there are a million
light years across they're enormous
they're bigger than the entire galaxies
but what yesterday's result was about
was seeing it attach itself
threaded through the black hole so we
can see it's so close to the event
horizon of the black hole that it really
validates the idea that it's the black
hole that's okay it just occurred to me
I know you all fans of science you
wouldn't be here otherwise but let's
make sure we're on the same page
okay okay
so tell us what a black hole is right
that's a good
slide you know I was just like oh when
are they going to get to this part
you should always ask always ask
yeah so Jenny tell us just give us the
basics of a black so a black hole is an
object with so much mass
in such a small space that not even
light can escape its gravitational pull
so is it fair to say that the escape
Velocity
which is the speed necessary to leave an
object Forever on Earth I I memorized
all these on Earth it's seven miles per
second so Chuck that old saying that
your grandmother said what goes up must
come down right not true not true my
grandmother was dumb as hell
so you can talk
she just didn't have intro physics this
is true right all right so if you can
throw faster than seven miles per second
it will leave Earth and never never come
back okay and so the sun has an even
higher escape velocity as you might
expect so a black hole the escape
Velocity is it fair to say it's greater
than the speed of light
even going at the speed of light you
could not escape the gravitational pull
of a black hole so I'm not I toss
something up and it comes back if I take
a beam of light on the black hole and
turn on the flashlight what happens to
the beam of light oh I love that one you
can actually get it to hang there
forever light with hang time so so that
the region that Jenny is talking about
Beyond which not even light can escape
is known as The Event Horizon and it's
just a demarcation line there's nothing
there poetic term or something that'll
just kill you
yes the Event Horizon you got to say it
does it sounds innocent you have to say
it's Smoky Lake yeah
but if you uh release a little pulse of
light exactly at the Event Horizon it
will try to race outward at the speed of
light but you can think of the Event
Horizon as a region where space time is
falling inward like a waterfall at the
speed of light and so it just sits there
oh look at that oh my God you just
described my marriage
good thing this isn't going to be on TV
or anything don't worry she's here
so Janet you wrote a book called the
black hole Survival Guide yeah which is
a little scary because you should not
come close enough to a black hole Yeah
to ever have to think about surviving it
yeah is what I'm thinking yeah spoiler
alert it doesn't end well yeah okay so
so you described you said that black
holes are nothing
yeah they are no thing yeah they're not
a thing they're not a thing they're not
a thing why are we here
you can you can think of a black hole in
some sense as a place
it's a place it's a region in space as
you said beyond which not even light can
escape but that that region that event
horizon is left like an archaeological
record on the space-time the thing that
formed the black hole maybe it's a
collapsing star
it can no more sit at the Event Horizon
then it can race outward at the speed of
light
so once it gets collapses under its own
weight and it forms this region where
everything goes dark it is forced to
continue to collapse and leave behind an
empty space with nothing it's a prisoner
of itself yeah oh
so it's gravity created its own cage in
a sense yeah and and when the star forms
it it is forced to disappear as well
down the black hole the black hole it
it's like dispenses with the Stars so
whatever made it is gone so if you go up
to that edge of that Horizon it's as
undramatic as stepping into the shadow
of a tree there's nothing there
so when people think of a black hole
it's a solid object clearly it's not it
is not space yes it's a place a region
of space okay so what's some background
on this Jenny can you tell me what when
did the black hole physics come on
online
well so one of the really cool things to
me is that when I learned about gravity
in high school you know I learned that
it was a we went to the same High School
not at the same time because I'm an old
fart but we went to the same height the
Bronx High School of Science Bronx High
School science Bronx in the house today
where I learned that gravity was a force
of attraction because objects have mass
but light doesn't have mass
so there's this magical thing that it's
actually bending in space and time which
light also moves through space and time
and so knows the effects of gravity so
the very first thing was we had to have
this idea of general relativity general
relativity so that's Albert Einstein
your favorite man my favorite yeah yeah
you guys should know this that there's
an ongoing feud between these two
whereas of course uh Neil my Newton
friends
yes and her man is Einstein and often
it's wonderful to get drunk and watch
them fight
about who is better
Isaac Newton discovered the laws of
Optics the laws of gravity
and uh he also stabbed himself in the
eye with a stick to test out the rods
and cones hey let me just say
doesn't sound like a genius to me
but he did all of that and decided to
invent integral and differential
calculus it's pretty impressive then he
turned 26.
mic drop oh
all right Jenna your response
well Einstein said of himself you know
when I was a student I was no Einstein
[Laughter]
all right let me clear up a couple so we
needed Einstein to advance these ideas
but Einstein did not
even come up with the idea of a black
hole actually we can go farther back in
time okay I went to the late 1700s okay
there's a physicist named John Mitchell
all right John Mitchell forgotten
long forgotten he is because until you
said it I still don't know who he is
John Mitchell wondered once the speed of
light had been established he wondered
could its star be so massive
that the light cannot escape and that
the Stark turns dark
and he called them dark dark stars
so this is the brilliant even before
Einstein before he had the math tools to
do this he Advanced this concept
and oh by the way John John Mitchell I I
have on here in my notes which I think
is fascinating he all his work was
forgotten no one knew about this he had
to be rediscovered literally nobody knew
nobody here knows okay okay there's no
picture of him
and he was described by someone this is
fascinating because in England of having
he was black of complexion oh
okay so either he had bubonic plague
or he was a black man okay
is bubon playing Black Death is that
right that's the Black Death that's the
Black Death that's why they called it
that because yeah you know you actually
turned black yeah which is why it gets
such a bad rap
there's no picture of him so we actually
portrayed him in Cosmos and we had a
black actor portraying just just put him
in there didn't even mention anything
about it uh it was just how fitting that
a black man discovered the black hole
okay
behave yourself
when we think of black holes we think of
this voracious
vacuum cleaner that whichever direction
it it just eats things up
so is that accurate
well as we have discussed
things can't usually fall directly into
a black hole okay
they they have some energy
and so actually they tend to orbit swirl
swirl okay black hole
and and this stuff that doesn't sound
like a very good vacuum cleaner if
stuff's got a swirl first down like an
awesome toilet
so Cosmic toilet okay so this whole
thing that black holes suck yeah vacuum
play that this is wrong it's very
overblown if our sun right now were to
turn into a black hole it would be best
that it currently has the mass
change it some Evil Genius comes along
figures out how to shrink it to a black
hole it becomes six kilometers across
it's really tiny little thing
um our orbit is America what's six
kilometers
I'll tell you what it is none of my damn
business
it's about four miles across I've lost
miles a long time
um yeah so it would fit inside New York
City you know okay
um uh our orbit would be just fine so we
would no more be sucked into a black
hole then we are sucked into the sun on
there would be very little detectable
difference in terms of of the Earth's
orbit we'd be we'd be perfectly fine so
this is a completely overblown it
rapidly freeze to death that would be
bad okay so don't say we'll be fine okay
the earth the earth would be fun the
Earth would just keep right on planetary
yeah
the rock would persist in its orbit we
would be gone yeah okay all life on
Earth but
there's life that thrives under sea that
absorbs energy from undersea vents which
is left over heat from the formation of
earth right so depending on your age in
the audience I am of that age we learned
that from our biology textbooks that all
life on Earth requires sunlight to
survive take away the sunlight we'd all
die that's before we had discovered this
life forms thriving at the bottom of the
ocean that are part of what we call
extremophiles life forms that do the
backstroke where the sun don't shine
where the sun don't shine right and so
uh just to be clear yeah yeah surface
life would rapidly die yeah you got to
get really close to a black hole is the
point really really close this thing's
only six kilometers across you got to
get within like 20 kilometers of it I
mean you're right on top which I have no
intent yeah and don't do it to the Sun
either because that would also
I'm going to ask that you guys stop
speaking in metric terms
[Laughter]
no you could um
NASA did a research study they found
that you can send astronauts to the sun
provided you visit at night
the same
uh Jenna why
if Einstein invented the framework
to understand and even predict black
holes
a why didn't he predict black holes he
did not that's right it wore white and
when he learned about him why was he in
denial of them yeah so he gets a letter
from a friend who's an astronomer who
has enlisted in uh the German infantries
a German infantry Soldier during World
War one and he's on the Russian front
during the war and the apocryphal story
is that between calculating ballistic
trajectories in the war he's reading the
preceding of the profession Academy of
Sciences
in which Einstein has published his
final description in mathematical terms
you know he Nails it general relativity
the theory of curb space time and Carl
shortshell does this little thought
experiment he says imagine the entire
match well people are shooting at him
yeah
he's uh yeah in the trenches hiding and
calculating and he does this beautiful
thought experiment he says imagine you
crush the entire mass of a star to a
point he doesn't ask how this is
possible or how nature could do such an
absurd thing that's not really of
interest to him initially he just says
imagine it and then he asks of
Einstein's equations to reveal to him
what the nature of the curved space time
is as a result of that and he writes
down it's a thought experiment with the
math and he writes down the first
description that has in it an event
horizon a region Beyond which not even
light can escape and it has all the
descriptions of the space-time around a
black hole Einstein's very impressed by
this he couldn't believe it's six months
after Einstein publishes his theory and
he he thinks this is terrific he helps
him get it published but Einstein thinks
you know nature is going to protect us
from their formation after all how are
you possibly going to crush a star to a
point and so he doesn't think that
they're going to be real he thinks there
are
nature yet to be discovered is going to
save his ass
well there are lots of laws that weren't
that were there like I can't crush this
glass to a point it's really hard it
resists pressure you know there's matter
has pressure if you were a real
housewife you'd be able to do that
I mean it was senseful
I wouldn't do that over a glass of water
exactly so there was there was sensible
reason to believe that matter would
resist being crushed okay
so this is not sensible reason I would
call it a bias
a bias that he had because he didn't
think nature would do that
okay so now when did we have our first
evidence of a black hole well we had our
first
evidence of black holes I believe in the
20s but I don't think we figured it out
until seven so when did we first figure
out that we had evidence of a black hole
in the 1970s 1970 so this is 50 years 60
years after Einstein
okay so so I what's this famous bet
between
Stephen Hawking and not in Einstein and
Kip Thorne remind us who Kip Thorne is
Kip Thorne is a very brilliant uh
relativist his a lot of his work as a
scientist was in the area of curb
space-time Big Bang black holes uh
wormholes that sort of thing he won the
Nobel Prize recently fairly recently in
the past few years for his work 2020.
yeah in in discovering uh or theorizing
about the Collision of two black holes
ringing space-time like a drum and when
it was eventually observed a project
that he was involved in for more than 50
years he received the Nobel Prize along
with his collaborators and he's also
wrote the treatment for Interstellar the
movie the movie he was a slapper he only
wrote the treatment he was listed as
executive producer of the series did you
guys see Interstellar
okay wait who has not seen Interstellar
okay security notice they did nothing
notice they didn't Clap
the people who saw it were like yeah
yeah like who has not seen it I'm I'm
okay
but by the way those who remember it
there's a robot in it that are these
sort of funky rectangular legs yeah do
you remember the name of that robot
no well there were several but the lead
one
it was called Kip it was called Kip then
robots
that's how you get your get your
situation in the situation I remember
that because he told him to turn down
the humor and I was like I'm done with
this movie
all right so there's a bet between
Stephen Hawking and Kip Thorne yeah
Baptist
whether or not we actually had the data
Justified
for a black hole so what was the first
black hole
well I know it was a
Stellar Mass black hole so 10-ish Suns
with a star friend and the black hole is
slowly
eating material from the Star so the
black hole is flaying the star yeah okay
so they should call them vampire holes
for real yeah
so I remember uh because this swirling
material that you began describing
earlier can get very hot
and start radiating in in a form of
light that you get when you have very
hot gas such as exercise and so when we
first had x-ray telescopes we started
this discovering these sources of x-rays
that didn't there was nothing else
obvious happening in that region of
space and one of them was a strong x-ray
Source in the constellation cygnus and
so it was essentially called cygnus X1
so I remember I was alive because that's
how old I am when that was discovered we
were very excited we read all about it
is that still to this day a confirmed
black hole Yeah Yeah
but it is worth pointing out that that
doesn't mean we could see the black hole
like you couldn't resolve the black hole
you were deducing that the object that
was emitting this incredible high energy
you could tell had a certain amount of
mass and was very very small and you
deduce from that that it's a black hole
but all you could see with the x-rays so
you couldn't see the black hole itself
and I think this surprised people to
learn that we really didn't see a black
hole for many decades let me just
understand this and I'm serious when I'm
asking this are you saying that the
x-rays were emanating from the black
hole is that that the black hole is
spewing out x-rays intimidating from
around the block what's that from around
the black hole it's this stuff that's
trying to fall into the box it doesn't
learn anything they said nothing comes
out of a block and that's my point so
how are you seeing something when
nothing can escape it how are you seeing
anything around it that's what I want to
know it's because this reputation of
black holes sucking up everything is
over alone things can live very close to
the event horizon of a black hole be
very hot and YouTube what's happening in
those discs right so the stuff gets
that stuff is swirling around it wants
to get into the black hole but it has
some energy right and so it can't just
fall right in right so what nature does
is orbital energy it has orbital energy
that's right it forms these discs
accretion disks okay and what happens in
the disc is that the gas cozies up with
itself it gets really nice and close
when it gets hot it gets hot it rubs
against itself it gets hot okay and this
is super exciting for astronomers
because what how astronomers study the
universe is by gathering light right and
so without that stuff near the black
hole we wouldn't have found it
we're not seeing anything from the black
hole itself all we're seeing is what's
happening around the black hole and that
excited material that gets all like hey
man we bout to go until
and then it gets hot and it gets excited
and then we see that as light and that's
how of high energy weight high energy
wavelength exactly and so so it gets
what the hell is wrong with you people
that is amazing okay wear it right so I
just learned something I don't know
about you but that is amazing okay wait
that is amazing
so what's raising we see nothing and we
know everything from saying nothing all
right
okay Chuck just blew a gasket we gotta
bring we gotta repair this is why I love
doing this show I'm sorry this is this
is why I do it that's amazing go ahead
I'm sorry okay Chuck will be in for
repairs this weekend so this friction is
the gas spiraling down losing that
energy that it had and it's got to end
up slow enough to drop in it's circling
the drain the train yeah the toilet the
toilet
we've done this in cold weather but you
can just do it now rub your hands it
doesn't take much rubbing to feel the
temperature of your hands go up just do
it you know the result but just try it
right first clap them and then do that
and then go heal somebody
first he clap do you run yeah and now
you're here
I told you Chuck needs repairs
all right so was there a bet and who won
it who bet on what oh so okay Stephen
Hawking Kip is the loveliest guy and he
he's he's he's a straight shooter he's
going to vote for the black hole and uh
Steven was a bit of a trickster and he
had this kind of a nimical quality she's
on first name Steven with Stephen
Hawking oh that's so obnoxious I'm sorry
Hawking was a bit of a trickster and so
his uh heat bed against black holes even
though so much of his life had been
devoted to understand them I think he
also suspected they were that they were
observing a black hole but he just
wanted to you know he he wanted to bet
the I don't know be the opposition be
the antagonist be the devil's advocate
so yes he bet against kip but he did
capitulate pretty early on and I think
the story is he's he broke into Kip's
office at Caltech or some said wait
Stephen Hawking did this yeah
what point in his life was
what I don't
know that's a detail left out in the
story I'm just trying to let that one go
I'm just saying we'll let that one go
okay okay so he he repelled down the
bill
I mean I would believe it I would never
even figure out a way to repel down a
building
you know yeah to break into Kip's office
yeah okay and so Sam what happened when
he broke into the office well I think he
left him and no conceding okay conceding
the BET okay okay so that's odd for him
to be anti-black hole because
because of his intellect we know so much
about black holes so one of them is like
black holes are not forever yeah so what
do black holes do when left to their own
devices well okay so this is a very
subtle issue because Chuck already
raised it the black hole lets nothing
from the inside out again but Hawking
figured out this very clever way the
black hole could kind of Steal energy
from empty space
and I don't think you want me to get
into this whole thing because this is a
whole big thing but but there's this
possibility that empty space sort of you
know has this frothing quantum
foam that sort of works
and it is only when Hugh introduced the
quantum that this happens only then and
he figured out a way that the black hole
could steal a little from the empty what
you're saying is Newton gravity Einstein
gravity alone doesn't get you this
result that's not he has to bring in
Quantum absolutely which is the physics
of the small yeah to describe something
that's going on in the physics of the
Lord and yeah there's children out there
sometimes when Newton gravity really
loves Einstein grass
they get together and they make a
quantum
so so it's
is this when we hear that black holes
evaporate so what happens is the black
hole ultimately evaporates it actually
uh gets less massive and it exposes
something in the vacuum that has to
radiate away so it doesn't come from
inside the black hole but it's in tandem
with this Quantum process but what it
looks like from afar is it looks like
the black hole is evaporating it is
emitting particles at a hot temperature
and it is getting smaller in the process
when I first learned this you know what
freaked me out and maybe it'll blow
another gasket for Chuck when I first
learned this it was like wait a minute
it is spontaneously creating particles
out of the gravitational field outside
of the Event Horizon
outside of the event right so the energy
there spontaneously becomes matter the
matter escapes and the mass of the black
hole drops
so what's inside the Event Horizon
loses Mass to stuff that's happening
outside the Event Horizon all right I
gotta go smoke some weed
laughs
that's exactly right it essentially
absorbs what we would consider to be a
negative energy particle in favor of
emitting a positive energy particle you
could say something like negative
energies don't exist but because of the
relativity of space and time inside the
black hole you don't think it's a
negative energy you think it's a
negative momentum and so it's completely
consistent with the laws of physics I'm
leaving with Chuck right now
yo that is still what just described is
what Harry Potter would call Magic yeah
so where did the term black hole come
from oh so that's a great story because
uh schwartzell didn't call her black
hole Einstein didn't call it a black
hole it was 1967 I believe in the great
John Wheeler who was the kind of
granddaddy of all of Relativity in
America
yes student Einsteins and he trained Kip
Thorne and Richard Feynman and all of
these great people
um he was on stage near Columbia like
above Tom's Diner you know from Seinfeld
swear I swear and giving a lecture it
wasn't Tom's Diner I don't believe in
the 1967 and he kept saying the end
state of catastrophic gravitational
collapse over and over again and
apparently from the back row somebody
shouted how about black hole and uh and
he just took it and foisted it on all of
us and one day he wrote something to the
effect like the Cheshire Cat the Star
Fades from view one leaves behind only
at smile the other leaves behind only
the black hole I I butchered that a
little bit but it's something like that
and with that uses it was honest
because nobody will never know who he is
and and he came up with the actual name
all right Jenny you focus on
supermassive black holes and
I you know we we Bandy about the word
super so often that it almost loses
meaning I'd like you to sort of give it
give it strength and presence once again
so what's a supermassive black hole
what's an ordinary black hole is there a
mini black hole what what is the mass
range and where do we find these beasts
yeah so usually when we say super
massive we're thinking about Million
Suns that's the black our own black hole
at the center of the military so we say
A Million Suns you mean take the mass of
a million of our Suns and cram it into
one object to make a black hole a
million a million and by the way if the
sun were Hollow you could pour a million
Earths into it
so a million a million million million a
million million is what a supermassive
black hole is correct okay right the low
end the the what the low end yeah they
can be a trillion yeah so the the friend
we talked about earlier where we saw the
base of the jet m87 we know we've seen a
picture of its Event Horizon that's a
billion Suns
that's how you do that okay so go on
right so when I was a kid we also had
the sigx ones of the world these are
like the mass of the Sun but a bit
bigger so maybe ten Suns
now ligo we've seen black holes where
we've heard black holes is the
abbreviation of the telescope the
gravity telescope that Kip Thorne
pioneered laser interferometer
gravitational wave Observatory okay so
go on and if where's the wave see every
time y'all say that I'm like there's no
W but never mind
astronomers love their acronyms don't
let real words
[Laughter]
go ahead so so for for all time it was
ten Suns and then a million sons and one
of the amazing things for me as an
astronomer that ligo has taught us is
that it's actually these Stellar Mass
black holes go all the way up to 100
Suns at least but that still leaves a
big space between a hundred and a
hundred thousand or a million and we
just have no idea we just don't know
okay so we don't even know what
mechanism could create such an object
well so with the Tanish Sun black holes
that's a dead fat star that is the death
of the star yes and then these things up
to a hundred they seem to be
probably the mergers of those of those
okay right because we don't want to see
them merging that's that Chuck you see
what she did there it's like we don't
know how to make those so let's add the
others together and that's how you do
that but ligo has detected 30 and 30 or
60 and 30 merging to the 100
. so you just staple together the ones
that are match is that what you're doing
well not with the super mess not with a
staple gun
[Laughter]
guys are witnessing first science fights
nerd fight all right so so I just admit
we don't know what could make a 30 to
100 solar mass black hole no no 30 to
100 you can but a million we don't know
a million we have no idea but you
haven't detected a million yet yeah like
the super masters of the center
breakouts
four million okay and and the one you
mentioned m87 is 0.5 million we will
resurrect this argument about how
massive the black holes are and what in
the universe is making them not this
size Matters
on start talk
[Applause]
we're back for Segment two at the
Keswick Theater Philadelphia
all right
I got with me John 11.
black hole extraordinaire expert and
Jenny green a professor at Princeton
University and we have Chuck nice okay
so
so in this segment we want to spend a
little more time on detecting the
undetectable
and of course
uh you know our our friend the one with
black complexion uh gave us gave a first
indication John Mitchell of how you
might detect it and that was if a star
is black
dark and will get pulled over by the
star police
in a second
you know why I stopped you I was not
doing
not doing it in the speed of light yeah
[Music]
but we clocked you at 1.5 feet away
the speed of light not it's not just a
good idea it's the law yeah
uh so he's supposed because by then we
knew that there were stars that were
double they were double Stars more than
half the Stars you see in the night sky
come in at least pairs in some cases
tripled and even entire clusters so the
isolated star is not even all that
common
and the only I would say single correct
science out of all 30 Star Wars movies
Star Wars movies uh was in
the first Star Wars one which I think
they call Star Wars part four
um that's right where they show Luke was
it the sand planet and he comes out and
there's a double Sunset right on the
horizon yeah they said somebody finally
did this
uh and so more power to the people who
thought that up that's the only thing
they got right that's the only thing
they got right in the entire series just
thought I'd put that out there
you want to fight meet me outside we'll
we'll
after school
so what he said so
do we Loop the
you don't otherwise see anything there
there's something dark has gravity and
it's tugging on it
so let's so Jenny pick us up from there
all right now we left off when we began
with a with this Jets and the thing and
all this stuff and Chuck blew a gasket
here in that we still can't see black
holes
we got an hour and a half show on
Blackout and we still can't see him so
what are the clever ways that ingenious
astrophysicists have come up with to
detect them right so this is why I'm on
team Newton because almost all the ways
that we find black holes actually don't
even need general relativity it's just
Newton's Laws right like I said Janet
I'm I'm gonna be the one waiting for you
outside
[Laughter]
right so the star friend of Sig X1 we
can watch it going around Sig X1 and we
can figure out there must be a really
dense object there just like planets
going around the sun we can figure out
the mass of the black hole and in fact
we can do the same for the black hole at
the center of our own Galaxy
um Sage star and so there's a black hole
so the Milky Way has its own black hole
we have our own supermassive flash we
have lots and lots of Stellar Mass black
holes and we agreed that's four million
times four million and so that thing
about black holes is that they're
spatially small so that's less than 20
times the width of the Sun but it's four
million times the mass so picture the
sun on the sky you know don't stare at
the Sun but like picture the sun the sky
imagine just you know 20 times across
and this thing and they cram a million
four million four million
yeah and then push it twenty six
thousand years away and it's like a tiny
teeny little thing on this guy so it's
about as big on the sky as people like
in it to a piece of fruit on the moon so
it's really tiny and that's why black
holes are so challenging because despite
their heft they're spatially small
so so small and Hefty
all right so we have this rain there are
many jokes I'm not doing right
I'm of the age where black holes in the
centers of galaxies was a new idea we
found them in one Galaxy and then
another random other Galaxy and as we do
in my field if you find it in this
galaxy next then all galaxies must have
it that was the driving presumption and
sure enough when Hubble came online it
had good views down in the centers of
galaxies and bought a bank we have yet
to find a Galaxy that does not have a
supermassive black hole is that correct
uh I guess not okay it's not correct
sorry
meet me outside
we'll settle this in the parking lot
big galaxies big galaxies like our Milky
Way or m87 yeah so far as we know they
all are most
here's the real question have we found
galaxies where there are not super
massive big galaxies yeah red blooded
gout American gallery
no like like the kind of Galaxy you were
put in the back of a cosmic pickup truck
pickup truck with a gun rack you got one
of those
we have smaller galaxies that don't have
black holes is it possible we have not
yet asked for their passport so we can
try that all right okay I got it all
right so now this galaxy one of the most
massive galaxies in our catalogs is in
the Virgo cluster super cluster of
galaxies because galaxies cluster the
way Stars call us they're very cliquish
that that's the the universe just doing
its thing with gravity so we have the
Virgo supercluster there's thousands of
galaxies the most massive Galaxy in that
is in the Messier catalog Messier was a
French astronomer in the 1700s and an
awesome hockey player
he wanted to make a catalog of fuzzy
objects in the night sky
so that you don't confuse them for
comments that you might be trying to
discover
pretty cool man so they told the Messier
catalog and this is this it's it's
really the catalog of not comets but it
turned out to be a catalog of the most
famous fuzzy objects in the night sky
including Messier 87 which is this
supermassive Galaxy it's far enough away
it's just a smudge of light but it's got
trillions of stars so we recently the
astronomical Community recently
published a photograph of that black
hole tell me about it
we can actually see light swirling
around the Event Horizon because
astronomers are
incredible at working together to build
these pictures and as Janna said it's a
piece of fruit on the moon
in terms of how big it is so
so I've heard there's something called
The Event Horizon telescope that lets
you think there's like one telescope
sitting somewhere looking for black
holes but what is it actually so it's a
network of telescopes and what's
important for getting a tiny tiny
picture is that you put your telescopes
as far apart as possible so that you can
get this really really high angular
resolution so you're not getting
different
sets of data in principle you're getting
one coherent set of data as though the
telescope were as wide as the diameter
of the earth basically although you have
to work really hard to make the data a
bunch of cameras taking the same picture
yes and you get the resolution of
something as wide as Earth as though
your telescope let's blow your telescope
for that size but in fact you have all
of these different telescopes your
coordinating you have to combine them
they each have detectors that somebody
had to build and commission how many
total astronomers are involved in this
approximately 300 300 I don't know is it
bigger than that I look
and I'm like what
what I'm like I cannot believe they let
George on here
there are countries that historically
and even today
we're at war with one another
yet the scientists are collaborating
yeah can you comment on that oh yeah
yeah
somebody started applauding but yes that
deserves Applause
because quite frankly only these guys
can absolutely hate each other but love
science so much
that they will continue to work together
and that should be a model for the rest
of us to find right right in the
geopolitics of the world it should be
so the Nobel Prize in physics
um which includes prizes for astronomy
can only be awarded to three people or
less and there has been sort of a
discussion I don't know how seriously it
was taken that the Nobel Peace Prize
should be given to Major scientific
collaborations because they are working
both across things like the Large Hadron
Collider the James Webb Space Telescope
The Event Horizon telescope these are
examples of what human beings can do if
we put our minds to it International
politics yeah yeah interesting
absolutely here here
so you'd simply open up the Peace Prize
to not only the usual things that might
earn it but then the collaborations that
transcend governments
all right
so I want to get back to to this jet we
first started talking about yeah uh so
so we get this disc accretion disk which
was officially called around a black
hole by the way when I think of
accretion disk I kind of think of
the middle accretion disc around my
Equator the middle-aged man why are you
eating a crease no just
so okay we got through that and we
rubbed our hands and we figured this out
but now we have Jets so what's tell me
about Jets oh yeah
I'll talk about do you want to talk
about that go for it no you go for it I
I will tell you this about Jets Roger
she leaned in on that one yeah grabbed
the trick and before you do let me tell
you about this
when you're a jet you're a jet
from your first cigarette to your last
dying day
so I have these accretion disks how do
we get a jet out of that well the I
guess the exciting and beautiful thing
is we don't really know
oh okay it's got something to do with
the black hole the black hole's got a
lot of energy there are these particles
that are accelerated we think we're
getting the energy from the black hole
to power the jet but I'll tell you what
when I go to meetings about black holes
and accretion the jet session is when I
leave to go see the European town that
I'm visiting
that was like okay
that was cool
we've been we've been talking about how
to accelerate Jets and we just don't
know but I do think that the irony is
that what the black hole is basically
doing is it's acting kind of like an
electromagnetic battery so there are
these magnetic fields that are threaded
through the accretion disks that the
black hole can't do on its own it needs
that stuff around it and then the
churning of the space-time due to the
black hole actually basically creates a
gigantic battery which starts to power
these Jets so these jets are
electromagnetically powered and um and
so black holes go from being the darkest
phenomena conceivable as we discussed in
the beginning to to the largest uh
sources of electromagnetic power in the
universe that we can see at the edge of
the universe so is this an overload of
this electromagnetic battery that it
just can't contain all the energy that
is being generated inside the secretion
disc and all of a sudden you would
accelerate the party accelerates the
particles they get excited and they're
just like I'm out of here and that's it
well literally what it's churning up the
magnetic fields and then the magnetic
fields are literally like wires in a
circuit and the charges are currently
following an amount like they're
currents flying out on the circuit
that's the second thing I learned
tonight
it is amazing Chuck just blew a third
gasket on that all right so Jenny what
what tell me about your work with the
James Webb Space Telescope we've all
been Enchanted and and
stupefied by the beauty and majesty and
its access to previously Untouchable
parts of the universe so it's really
life-changing I would say it's like a
once in a career experience it's been
for me to see the James Webb say that
all right so as we said we said there
are stellarish mass black holes and
there are supermassive black holes and
then we don't know how to make the
supermassive black holes but we figure
they must have started out smaller
somewhere in this intermediate Mass
black hole regime where we can't find
any but for my whole career I've been
saying if we can find these intermediate
Mass black holes we can understand how
supermassive black holes form and I've
been saying we're never going to find
them back near the Big Bang early in the
universe because we just don't have the
telescopes so let's look for them nearby
and that's been most of my career and
now all of a sudden we put this you know
six meter gold-plated thing into space
and we are honest to God we're finding
the baby black holes you're finding baby
yeah oh my God are they cute
they are so cute
are they like Roku are they like little
baby Yodas I don't know how you would
feel if you saw the Spectra but when I
see it I'm like oh
you're reacting not to a photo of the
black hole you're reacting to a spectrum
of the energy emitted in the vicinity of
the black right it's the it's the
secretion disc again yeah and you just a
touch
it warms your it looks it looks like the
data that I gotta tell you
it kind of sounds like you're being
catfished
I really really hope not
yeah so these black holes you say
they're baby black holes that implies
they're young but are they actually
younger are they just small oh well so
oh Neil
all the black holes are young because
we're seeing them you know as they were
a few million years after the big bang
right because James okay so everything
is that age everything is Young yes
they're all adolescents back then oh
that's kind of dope as we see farther
out in space we look farther back in
time right so we see things not as they
are but as they once were
oh that sounds so romantic and now now I
feel like looking back at my life
okay
all right so so this is stoked your
career yeah wow
okay so so you're still studying them
there's anything you can share with us
about it anything new and exciting what
is Pandora's cluster I read about it
yeah so the the studies that I'm in some
study anything named Pandora yes right
right
that's really good
all right you already covered Galaxy
clusters yes right well this is a Galaxy
cluster it's got a thousand galaxies in
it or something and that means it sits
in a really big Dark Matter Halo
and we've already talked about how
space-time can bend light right so wait
pause what's a dark matter so dark
matter is a form of matter that does not
interact with light it's that simple
okay wrong answer what is dark matter we
don't know
[Laughter]
we walked into that one yes it's not
only that we don't know we have no
freaking idea I would I would say we
have a little bit of an idea because we
do know that it acts like matter and we
do know it doesn't interact with light
and we know that there are things like
neutrinos which exist which are
technically dark matter no question and
by the way probably shouldn't be called
Dark it should be called invisible like
if I had a handful of it it's not that
it would be dark it would literally be
invisible so it doesn't scatter light it
doesn't absorb light light goes right
through it so so we don't know what this
dark matter that makes up the 20-some
percent
so what you really should but you know
what has gravity so you should call it
invisible gravity well we know it acts
like matter in its pressure energy you
know it's equation of state of matter
looks like regular matter in that sense
okay so it's implicated as particles all
right whereas dark energy is not
particulate
presumably and also we don't know what
that is either and also it's not dark
it's also invisible this sounds like a
case for a science Angela Lansbury so
you've got this cluster in the middle of
a dark matter Halo so we have James Webb
already an incredibly powerful Telescope
yes but we use the power of
gravitational lensing to make it even
more powerful so because this invisible
mass is sitting between us and the very
early Universe the Galaxy's way back you
know
uh
500 million years after the universe
started further back in time than the
cluster you're studying that's right the
cluster is basically right here okay but
what we're we're using it for its mass
and it is like a lens it's it's lensing
these galaxies and so we can see even
smaller and even further back in time
because we're using the power
qualifications we are exploiting this
specifying effects of Einstein's general
relativity in the Distortion in the
fabric of space and time to see where
even that telescope the James Webb would
not have seen without that cluster is
that correct correct so my my colleague
Evo labe who runs this
survey he found so remember James Webb
was built to see had to have infrared
vision because as the universe expands
the light gets stretched out and so by
the time it reaches our telescope it's
redder than when it left its Galaxy so
we need these infrared goggles just to
be clear because I I don't know that
everyone fully appreciates that design
feature of the James Webb Space
Telescope because I remember old enough
to remember when we were specking what
it should do for us like no other
telescope before it and we said we want
to see galaxies being born well what
kind of light are they emitting well
they're emitting like ultraviolet
well how are we going to see it today
well over that time it's going to become
infrared
so we built a telescope to detect the
that used to be ultraviolet at the time
the galaxies were admitted thank God we
don't have that technology for actual
children
so it's an extraordinary achievement in
our understanding of the universe and
the power of our Technologies to make
that up just a shout out to the
engineers that Empower what we do as a
as scientist yes
okay so continue please
so my colleague Evo he's looking for
baby galaxies we have this this lens
this magnification to help us out and
what he finds are things that are way
redder than any galaxies we expect to
see and what he thinks he's found are
basically Universe breaking galaxies
they seem to be way bigger like the size
of the Milky Way already and no one
thinks there was enough time to make
those galaxies yet how did you make all
of those Stars so quickly because it
takes a certain amount of time for a
Galaxy to form and we don't have that
kind of time yes actual Singularity
that's what we're talking about let's
begin with so there's an incongruency in
the time itself
so these galaxies shouldn't exist in our
current understanding of the early
Universe yeah so it turns out it turns
out everybody knew at the time well the
other way everybody knew
now you all know how I feel all the time
okay what's the other way you can make
this very red thing that seems very
powerful it seems like it's powered by
lots and lots of stars but as we've
already established we have objects in
the universe called quasars correct
which can can generate intense energy in
the it's a regular Galaxy but the center
of it can generate intense energy and we
think
some of that intensity is because it's
aiming stuff at us is this where you
guys are landing well it's probably just
a regular accretion disc but it can make
a lot more light than than stars and so
now it hasn't collapsed into a black
hole there's a black hole in the middle
in the middle and it's this it's our
hands rubbing together that accretion
disc
so we think in fact instead of universe
breaking galaxies he actually found a
bunch of accreting black holes early on
okay oh all right so all right wait are
y'all y'all get this
that was some deep stuff man
so so come on look look no because I'm
serious that I just got what you're
saying is like basically you look back
you thought you found this galaxy that
was uh old enough to be a Galaxy but
it's too close to the singularity that
actually be a Galaxy yeah but really
what you found were a bunch of black
clones just hanging out like yo what you
up to man I know I haven't touched you
sitting there I have a little something
man like you know all these black holes
that have gathered and because we can't
see them what we're really seeing is all
the energy that all these black clothes
are giving off so it's not these old
galaxies it's a bunch of young ass black
girls
and that's what it means you got it
science right
okay
But Chuck I want to take a slightly
different view of this okay Jenny Neil
James Webb's discoveries five galaxies
that don't fit our understanding of the
universe so rather than allow our
understanding of the universe to break
you invented some explanation for it so
we can continue to think that we
understand the early Universe because
it's killed everything I said isn't that
what just happened here
well but the thing is that well but okay
what we got Spectra oh okay yeah
all right when we come back
we are going to dive into the belly of
the Beast and find out what the laws of
physics tell us of what could be going
on inside a black hole and whether any
of that physics and understanding of the
space-time Continuum would even allow
wormholes when start talk live at the
Keswick continue
[Applause]
and now the third and final segment of
StarTalk live at the Keswick theater
let's do this
I am with my comedic co-host Chuck Nice
hey hey all right we've got Jenny Green
from Princeton and we've got Channel 11
from Barnard in Columbia
two of the three of them are experts in
black holes yes
so we're in this segment
in this segment we're going to talk
about what's inside a black hole and can
is there time travel is that possible is
just let's go places that telescopes
have never been
let's go ahead and do that so Janet in
your in your recent book the black hole
Survival Guide oh I know right yeah will
you play you plan to when you plan
you build a space here
I'm not going to do the spoiler alert
but yeah but you take it you take it it
doesn't end well as we've described take
the reader on a journey towards a black
hole you cross the Event Horizon and
take it into the depths
of Oblivion
and she's laughing I know this is it's a
little semester this is a little worried
about this right here right here I'm
feeling a little Punchy right here all
right so tell us about that well we were
discussing how uh if you cross a big
enough black hole which all most black
holes are big enough for human beings
that uh when you cross it it's actually
quite undramatic you really don't notice
much there's literally a principle
called no drama which is the idea that
there shouldn't be anything special
happening at the Event Horizon so if you
did not know everything about black
holes and you simply saw this shadow
cast on the sky like maybe there's a
whole bright Galaxy behind it and you
can just see the shadow of the black
hole and you went and you approached you
would enter the Event Horizon and maybe
not even know you had done so
um but then Terrible Things begin to
happen so your book is very much like
Thanksgiving dinner
wait so Janet your book is mistitled
could you call it the survival guy yeah
but it's really your recipe for death
yeah the it is uh yeah it is definitely
ill-advised to actually cross the Event
Horizon because it is a guaranteed death
experience because you're not coming
back you're definitely not coming back
okay here's a subtle way you might come
back okay oh there's a way back there's
okay there's a tiny way back so we
talked about Hawking and people have
been arguing about this whole Hawking
thing for a long time so if black holes
evaporate eventually the black hole
disappears in this event horizon which
is like this curtain blocking everything
that happens inside the black hole
separating it forever from us outside
you're in you're never coming out no
information comes out when the black
hole evaporates it's like the curtain's
been yanked up and where did all that
stuff go and so this has been a really
hotly debated topic for a long time and
you might say it just disappeared but
but physics doesn't allow that sort of
thing that breaks physics and
um and so people have been arguing well
maybe the information actually does come
out
of the black hole information that was
previously lost by having fallen into it
and the information could be that it's
Neil deGrasse Tyson and it's all your
quantum numbers and it's all the way
you're organized it's in your entire
life history and if you fell into the
black hole we would never ever be able
to get that information out except
through this really subtle magical thing
Hawking discovered of the radiation so
maybe if I wait outside the black hole
long enough and I collect every detail
of that information that came out I
Could reconstruct you from that Quantum
information oh it's like every Star Trek
transporter episode yeah
okay all right so
so I put you back together again so tell
me about if if you actually greet the
singularity at the bottom of the black
hole
then you should at some point Have
Become spaghettified yeah well you're
the king of the spaghettifications and
you tell it better than anybody I mean
I'm not gonna kneel DeGrasse taste it
yeah
it's your turn
count of spaghettification all right
you guys seated
okay so what happens is
as I stand here on Earth
you can you don't feel this but you can
calculate that because my feet are
closer to the center of gravity of the
earth than my head is
that Earth is actually pulling on my
feet more strongly than it is at the top
of my head because my feet are closer
you don't feel that difference you can
calculate it is insignificant at all the
molecular structure of my body resists
that on a level that you don't even
notice
well that's because I'm here six feet
two and the radius of the Earth is four
thousand miles
and six feet relative to six thousand
kilometers
all right but now watch we get one at
Janna's small black holes
and I'm Falling Towards The Singularity
now my height becomes significant
relative to the distance that I have
left to fall
so the gravity at my feet
gets stronger and stronger and stronger
relative to the gravity at my head and I
begin to stretch
now initially a stretch who doesn't like
a good stretch oh so refreshing and then
until you realize this is not stopping
and the these are called tidal forces
yes it's the stretching force of
gravity's difference from one side of
you to the other it's when the black
hole gets medieval on your ass
[Music]
thought of it that way that is totally
one of those racks you know where they
try to
yeah Medieval Times always trying to rip
you apart somehow somehow drawn in
quarters
okay so you're falling in you feel the
stretching and then you realize this is
not stopping and it's no longer
comfortable
and it reaches a point where the tidal
forces exceed the molecular binding
forces of your flesh and you split
you split likely at the base of your
spine now you work two parts Falling
Towards The Singularity and they feel
the tidal Force
of the black hole and so those two parts
stretch
you will probably still be alive at this
point because you don't you have
important organs but not vital organs
below your waist right so it's like when
you see that uh zebra getting eaten by
the Lions and it's looking down at them
like I can't believe y'all eating me man
that's messed up man I can't believe
that y'all y'all are eating me
so so you bifurcate first into two parts
then your bottom half and upper half
bifurcate again
and that next one will probably sever
you at your neck
and you might survive that a little bit
experiments during the French Revolution
where you're just chopping heads you
might as well participate in a science
experiment while they're doing this
exactly that the eyes connect directly
to the brain don't require the rest of
your body right
okay
if you want French people smoke
because we do okay especially when we
are at the beach
so you go from two to four to eight to
16 32 and you bifurcate
all the way down until even the
molecules that previously held you
together the tidal forces end up
splitting those
and you become this stream of atoms
descending to this Cosmic abyss and
that's not even the worst part
as you're falling in
your being funneled down
to a narrower and narrower volume of
space-time
so you're not only getting stretched
head to toe you're being extruded
through the fabric of space-time like
toothpaste through a tube
when you step back and look at this
basically there's no other way to
describe it you have been spaghettified
[Laughter]
and the whole time that that is
happening
you are hearing when the moon hits your
eye
all right so so suppose you survive your
trip through the Event Horizon okay
what's this stuff you can see the back
of your head what what is that oh well
that's that's an actual Optical effect
yeah that can that can even happen just
outside the Event Horizon actually
there's a point where if you were
shining light on your face and the light
was reflected off uh or actually Shining
Light in the back of your head it was
reflected off the back of your head it
could travel all the way around the
black hole and you could see it because
even the light you see the back of your
head the light gets caught in orbit just
like the International Space Station
orbits the earth you can put light in
orbit around a black hole so you get
really cool so it's basically the
photons are orbiting around so that your
eyes are receiving the same information
from the back of your head yeah that you
are looking at so you can see the own
back yeah yeah
but what is interesting is inside a
black hole um you know there's this
whole black holes are dark and all that
lore is completely true from the outside
but black holes can be bright on the
inside because the light from the entire
galaxy can fall in behind you and so as
you're on your way towards the
singularity the light travels faster
than you do and it can catch up to you
and you can watch the entire history of
the Galaxy unfold sped up for you the
future history the future history we
could watch the Earth find out what
happens with the whole climate change
thing yeah oh believe me we'd already
know
you can watch all the stars in the
galaxy expire I mean depending on how
long you take to get down there and so
it actually is quite bright for you
inside a black hole it's like all that
light gets crushed towards you as you're
Falling Towards The Singularity and Mark
in front it's dark outside and bright
inside right because the light can't
escape but the light is still in the
light can fall in the light overtakes
you because you're just falling at a
rate of gravity but the light is coming
in at the speed of light that's right
and it and it's all crushed together
others you see a very bright white flash
of light just as you're approaching the
singularity and it's like you know the
light at the end of a tunnel right it's
like a near-death experience except it's
a total yes it's a total death
experience yes
beautiful and then your face melts right
all right so
we've gotten this far
and on Einstein's gravity
but we know or at least the equations
tell us that all this matter collapses
down to a singularity
which Disturbed Einstein there's got to
be something that stops IT
so is this the edge
of General relativities relevance in the
universe I do believe that this because
are we dividing by zero there yeah the
singularity is what it really is is it's
predicting for those who don't remember
from their math class you're not
supposed to divide by zero okay so we
have Mission here yeah where your
equations blow up yeah you're getting an
infinite curvature infinite
gravitational energy density and and I
don't think anyone really believes that
that's what actually happened so you
have to abandon General relatives I
think it's like general relativity is
signaling its own failure and it is it
is saying when you get to those high
energy scales we know that we have to
invoke quantum mechanics because as you
said Quantum is of the very small so
here you're in a very tiny tiny region
of space where the energy is very high
and there's no way you can talk about it
without understanding quantum gravity
and we don't understand quantum gravity
so we know that the singularity isn't a
declaration of what's true we know that
it's telling us that we need to
understand quantum gravity before we'll
really know what's going to happen in
the center so I have a book don't we
have the same problem with the quantum
that we do with black holes is that we
can't see the quantum well you mean in
the in the center the we can't see the
quantum in a conventional human way
because we're a big macro scale but
we've learned to probe the quantum in a
very compelling way that we have it it's
the most accurate predictions in the
history of science we get from quantum
mechanics that are confirmed by
experiment so it is stunning it is
something we don't really understand
very well it's very elusive but our
predictions predictions it's very spooky
freaky predictions but but but the
accuracy exceeds the accuracy of any
scientific prediction prediction in the
history of of human culture so if you're
a betting man you would say that at the
singularity quantum physics absorbs
General relatives I'm going to rewrite
the story and it might rewrite the story
with little things like wormholes so it
might be good as you get into there this
might be a crazy idea I actually don't
think it's that crazy but uh that when
you get to the quantum scale inside the
black hole you realize that there are
these little wormholes Quantum wormholes
that are negotiating the interior and
the exterior of a black hole without
traveling inducing faster than speed of
light travel and
um and in fact one of the really spooky
ideas is that in fact the black hole is
totally made up of these Quantum
wormholes and so it's like imagine
embroidering a circle and it's you look
like you have this big Dark Shadow but
when you look closely you realize it's
just these Tangles of thread and so at
the quantum level we might realize that
the black hole its shadow The Event
Horizon all of it is really woven out of
these Quantum wormholes
Chuck you got that weed ready I'm
telling you
Jesus
that is that's like wild it is wild and
that's how the Hawking radiation would
get out I got one more spooky thing yeah
you ready yeah I ran the numbers on this
because uh large black holes are not on
average dense other than the singularity
big black holes have slightly different
macroscopic properties like you uh how
should I say so
let me put it another way if you take
the mass of the universe
and then I ask it
how big a black hole
with the mass of the universe make
what would be the size of that event
horizon and it's the size of the Horizon
of the universe that we observe
so is the entire universe
a black hole as seen from the outside of
our Event Horizon and are we simply
alive enjoying the contents of our own
black hole
well we better get to enjoying it quick
because we all about to be crushed into
nothing that's for sure I'm just asking
well I I mean it's the Universe I would
not say the University of black hole but
I would say we do have an event horizon
as well cosmologically so inside the
universe we're looking at the expansion
of the universe and there is a region
which we can very well articulate around
us Beyond which light will never reach
us it is also an event horizon so the
Universe goes dark for us beyond that
point there are things we will never see
that's everything you said about the
black hole Yeah that's the universal
black hole it's still not a black hole
because we're we're not the thing about
a black hole is it's not just this
region of space that you can travel
around and paddle and survive forever
once you cross that event horizon that
Singularity is actually a point in your
future so I want to emphasize this if I
look at the black hole from the outside
I think that there's a center to it
because it's spatial I think it's round
I think there's a point in the center at
that point might be the singularity and
if you fall in maybe you could avoid it
but but when you're the person falling
in your space and time have rotated so
much that that Singularity is actually
not a point in space for you at all it's
a point in time and that Singularity is
in your future and you can no more avoid
it then you can avoid flowing forward in
time
okay I gotta go
y'all have a good night
I hope you enjoy the rest of the
conversation
oh wait so so
you you mean this literally not just
figurative yeah I mean it literally
black hole is in front of me in space
from the outside from the outside but
it's like across the Event Horizon
the rotation of the coordinate system is
such that the center
what I wouldn't want to think of as a
position in space that I might sidestep
it's no longer a position in space it is
on my timeline and I cannot avoid it and
I'm going to get crushed to that
Singularity it is now an inevitability
Mr Anderson
yes exactly damn that was a quote from
the Matrix in case you didn't see
yes my name
is Neil sorry
we're just geeking out here right now so
this is spooky stuff
I have a book on my shelf co-written by
Stephen Hawking I read it and didn't
completely understand it but I do
remember the pages where it said that on
the other side of a black hole an entire
other space time opens up
as though it has birthed in Another
Universe yeah that's a really profound
idea so what's really going on there
it's the Hawking and Ellis book right
yes very technical very beautiful book
um so what what to me it was an ugly
book because I didn't understand it it's
a beautiful it was painful though it was
painful so uh the idea I can't wait to
read it
what they're doing there is they're
saying you know this is kind of relevant
to your question earlier about cosmology
the Big Bang Singularity looks a lot
like kind of in the inverse of a black
hole Singularity so instead of
everything falling out of the universe
uh falling you know out of the black
hole everything in the Big Bang is
coming out of the singularity and so
they were like well maybe I should just
sew these two things together and the
interesting thing is mathematically In
This Very formal technical book they can
prove that the space times
mathematically can be sewn together
flawlessly and that's not a given wow
right and it's beautiful can sew them
together that's so they said oh maybe
when you start to go into the
singularity you're actually blown out
into a new Big Bang and that's another
beautiful thing is that the black holes
might be small on the outside and the
way we've described but they're much
much bigger on the inside like the
Tardis
it's Doctor Who's Tardis and they can be
as big as an entire universe on the
inside and that's a beauty of curved
space time allows you that kind of
trickery so it doesn't mean that we have
a prediction that that's what happens
it's just suggestive that the math
permits it all right let's get even more
freaky before we close this out so you
mentioned wormholes possibly being the
fabric of a black hole but how about the
wormholes in this science fiction sense
where I'm over here but now I walk
through a portal and then I'm over there
as is displayed in the marble uh
superhero
Doctor Strange or of course Rick and
Morty right okay so much better yeah
okay so
is there anything that prevents that
because clearly if that can exist it's
going to be used in some Einstein
theories yeah so wormholes are again a
mathematical possibility that we don't
understand how they're possible it might
be like black holes before we realize
they were real so we don't understand
what source of matter or energy will
keep that throat open they tend to want
to collapse and so we don't know of any
form of matter or energy in the actual
universe that keeps wormholes open and
allows us to transfer it's got to be
like a negative you're totally fine it's
got to be kind of a negative gravity we
don't know of anything but look there's
Dark Matter dark energy and we don't
know what those are either so nobody
should say we will never discover a form
of energy that can keep a wormhole open
but but uh you know who knows maybe it
will be related to the dark energy or
the dark matter so it is perfectly fine
to attach space-time with these little
bridges that part's completely easy
there's nothing wrong with that all
right last bit Jana before we call this
out in the the interstellar one of the
more poignant stupefying scenes was when
the spaceship was orbiting a black hole
I think they call it Gargantua and there
were a a black hole that had a planet
and some of the crew went down to the
planet
closer to the black hole because the
planet is orbiting the black and they
stayed far away they had completely
different timelines yeah tell me about
time dilation around a black hole Yeah
we actually even see the effect around
the earth so the the rate at which
literally our clocks tick it's slower
closer to the Earth than it is further
away so when we communicate with
satellites there's actually the
additional effect of the speed of the
satellite which I do believe causes a
greater dilation but we do see that you
can run the map it's actually less it is
less than the gravity so
um so it happens but around a black hole
it's so extreme that if this is part of
the rotation of space and time that we
were just discussing so if one astronaut
stays far from the black hole they both
have perfectly calibrated clocks the
other astronaut travels near near in the
black hole and as they do it's almost as
though they're rotating in space-time
such that their clocks are running
slower and slower and slower relative to
the person further away when you hit the
Event Horizon technically you've rotated
all the time away that's why the center
of the black hole is in the Futures time
Direction and not in the space Direction
I'm literally not expecting anyone to
understand that all right
yeah so what happened if you didn't see
the thing there's 11 of you we didn't
see the movie right okay it should have
removed already right so the astronaut
who stays far away so they have
abstracts up here when when we're down
on them on the planet with them and 20
minutes goes by and then they beam or I
forgot how to get back up to the ship
right and the folks on the ship
yeah and they hated 20 years yeah
they're like what is your call
yeah
and this this is a real effect we
literally see the effect even around the
earth we correct our phones correct for
the relativistic time dilation
Uber can find us where they took atomic
clocks and they did exactly that where
one about 40 years ago yeah yeah but
keep up with the century but it's
exactly what you're saying there it's
proven because there's an actual
experience well it's also proven because
we know that there are subatomic
particles which have incredibly short
lifetime sometimes if they're just
sitting in your laboratory they decay in
a fraction of a second but you boost
them near the speed of light and they
will appear to live for minutes wow it's
real right so you were saying your cell
phones so that's the origin of that is
the GPS satellites so the GPS satellites
are in a different gravitational field
right from us
so their clocks take at a different rate
event because of general relativity yet
all of our clocks are synchronized and
perfect because we correct we
pre-correct the GPS time for general
relativity so that it's correct on Earth
time
that's
science
all right so yes
so let me get some just some closing
thoughts
Jenny what can you tell us just about
life the universe and everything your
your your career being emboldened by
jwst I'll tell you my husband always
wants to know what's inside a black hole
so now I'm gonna go home and tell him I
learned what's inside a black hole
okay Janna
closing thoughts I do think it is quite
amazing that black holes are like
fundamental particles they're
fundamental to the universe in a way
that nothing else is that we don't
really understand so when the universe
was created it might have made black
holes in the same way it made electrons
they might be a fundamental property of
the universe and little Quantum exotic
thing we think of them as collapsed dead
stars and that is a brilliant way that
nature thought of to make black holes
just kill off some stars but they they
actually are not dead stars that's not
their that's just one vehicle for making
them and and we do think that black
holes might have been created in the
early universe and they were uh like as
heavy as a little pile of sesame seeds
but they were smaller than a proton
and um and those Quantum black holes
would have evaporated away like
firecrackers but they are they are very
profound and fundamental property of the
universe
uh chuck would you do you have a I do I
have several closing thoughts
but really I am so proud to see a
theater full of people as we discuss
these mind-expanding principles and we
talk about things that are so incredible
with respect to our being and the fact
that we can look up and look out and
wonder and the fact that you are here
gives me hope for this entire stupid
rock that we are all floating on
so I like maybe offer some closing
thoughts myself
that
one of the things we've noticed about
the universe
is that every time
a new telescope comes online
a new telescope not just that it's brand
new
and shiny but that it was conceived to
access the universe by looking through a
window that previously had not been
opened
by looking through a window that we
didn't even know was there
at some point someone has to say I think
there's something on the other side of
this window because I just discovered
this new window and no one's looked
through it before so we gather funds we
propose it gets peer-reviewed and the
telescopes
get developed once again by Engineers to
empower the science that we have and
what a journey this has been
we are in the Centennial decade
of the discovery of quantum physics that
was in the 1920s
and you know what actually happened
97 years ago
Edwin Hubble discovered that our galaxy
wasn't the only galaxy in the universe
that the fuzzy things that half of the
Messier had found were whole other
galaxies
in a sense Island universes they were
poetically referenced as he was using
the biggest telescope available in the
day
and so every time we do this
our minds are not only blown
when we put it back together our minds
have actually expanded
and we learn more and more about our
place in the universe
so one of the greatest gifts
to civilization are the discoveries
in astrophysics because we all look up
at night
yet when the star the Stars call to you
and they call to me I know they may
maybe you don't become an astrophysicist
but if you walk out at night and it's
not cloudy and the moon isn't out those
stars are screaming
and you've you've experienced this not
in the Northeast you visit so yeah okay
all right you go someplace
okay
know what I'm talking about
the universe calls to you
so I would claim
that the study of the universe opening
up these great portals not only the
theoretical portals but the but the
technological portals to the universe
that there's no
greater source of a cosmic perspective
than all the new understandings that
come down the pipe
that tell us
how big the universe is how old the
universe is
and then in a way looking back on Earth
it makes Earth all of them more precious
in the vastness of the universe this is
the only place we've got are we the
Shepherds we need to be
to assure our own Survival on our own
planet
so that the next Generations can be
proud of the decisions we've made
rather than embarrassed
by the decisions we didn't
think
so I think
and black holes are just another part of
that glorious story
a little more obscure really fun good
fodder for a science fiction
storytelling but I I wouldn't have it
any other way
and that is a cosmic perspective
now
I want to show you something
I have in my possession
an authentic child's lunchbox
the black hole the original Disney black
hole movie from like
1977 I remember when it was
this is the lunch box for that movie
now I had recently at the time that's
how old I am graduated from high school
and I saw this movie
and it was immediately one of my 10
worst movies of all time
there was no science in it even what I
knew as a senior in high school I could
have totally tricked out this film
it was an embarrassment
but I have The Lunchbox and so I want to
open this one up there
downtown
[Laughter]
I'm gonna open the lunch box
and it's a little thermos
so I opened the black hole
and I opened the lid
and I want to
we heard about
the black hole in the center of the
Milky Way
but here I have milky ways in the center
of the black hole one for each of you
[Laughter]
I love Milky Ways yay yay
that's it start talk at the Keswick
Theater Philadelphia
you
gen 11.
Jenny Greene
[Applause]
Chuck Nice
[Music]